speaking of uh subjects for your
documentary um is there some place that
sort of like the craigslist for
documentarians when it comes to
finding subjects or is it just a matter
of observation people that do
documentaries or just sort of voyeurs
and they find interesting yeah no it's
just it's life really i mean it's just
where what you see that interests you
you know when i was starting uh
the movie i did called border war it was
a
time in los angeles and it's still going
on when we started to see a bunch of
activity on the border with cartels with
human smugglers and drug smugglers
and
when i was trying to fund the film in
washington dc they weren't seeing the
same level of
concern and i was a little bit ahead of
the curve on that and they were saying
we don't see any border war what are you
talking about there's nothing going on
on the border so it's but it's really
observing around you what interests you
what will again what will sustain you
and so everything just walking down the
street and seeing are you into cars are
you into vintage planes are you into
uh you know an obscure musician like
sixto rodriguez for sugar man that uh
has an amazing story and a comeback
story um so it's just anything in life
that you think
is a story that you want people to
to know and and that you could
communicate to people and maybe bring a
better understanding to a topic
a cause
a historical event that you want to
revisit like errol morris did with the
fog of war
anything that
piques your interest in that that you
want to tell the story about
you